welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in the ventures endgame they have
slammed shut a big door in the MCU with
the death of Iron Man but opened all
kinds of windows as the many greedy
Gus's in this universe scramble to steal
the scraps the Starks tack
that's right marble these days is kind
of an awkward stark inheritance dispute
Avengers Graverobbers
and its marvel studios pivots to build a
new phase 4 out of the ashes of the old
this conflict could actually set the
stage for the upcoming MCU film
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings coming February 2021 as excited as
I am to see Samui you take on the master
of kungfu shang-chi in a world he got
apparently on Twitter I'm actually more
excited about the movies villain the
Mandarin played by Tony Leung and this
film's connection to the ten rings
because these are loose threads that
have been hidden in the MCU as Easter
eggs connected to Iron Man since the
beginning you remember Ben Kingsley
played a version of the Mandarin and
Iron Man 3 but he was revealed to be
this Patsy actor not the real Mandarin
and the ten rings is a shadowy terrorist
network through phase one of Marvel
Studios and they slipped back into the
shadows but what is the ten rings
exactly and how will this shang-chi film
explore their deeper mythology to pick
up the torch from Iron Man and Avengers
end game to complete the mandarins
long-running evil conspiracy kerala
warning in case any of my explanation or
speculation ends up telling you more
than you want to know about Chang ji and
that ruins your light so shine Qi is
known as the master of Kung Fu kind of
Marvel's comic book take on the
popularity of Bruce Lee this movie's
creative team has very intently made
adjustments in order to avoid some of
the offensive stereotypes from some of
the source material for example Shang
keys father who Manchu but once they
ever have this shang-chi film might do
that is that by instead making Shang
cheese father the Mandarin who in the
Marvel comics is a recurring villain
with ties to bashang Chi and iron man
and has a deeper connection to the ten
rings so in the MCU the ten rings first
appeared as the name of the terrorist
cell that kidnapped Tony Stark in the
first Iron Man they called themselves
the ten rings it's recent violence has
been
should be to a group of foreign fighters
referred to by locals as the ten rings
the ten rings is known by their logo a
chain of ten ring surrounding two swords
each ring containing a different icon
more on that in a bit
the ten drinks group and Ironman was led
by Raza who made a deal with Obadiah
Stane to trade Tony Stark as part of a
secret arms deal later the ten rings
were revealed to be a much wider
terrorist network with Roz's group being
just one franchise with several other
franchises around the world 110 rings
the agent showed up briefly in Iron Man
2 funding Ivan Vanko with a passport and
ticket to the Monaco race where whiplash
attack Tony Stark and they appeared in a
few MCU prelude comics with Nick Fury
Black Widow and Brody with their plans
to get Tony Stark's armor technology
always getting foiled the Rhodey one
ended with the tees of the ten rings
leader the Mandarin which seemed to be
setting up Iron Man 3 in which the
Mandarin was going to be the big bad but
as we saw in Iron Man 3 was actually
just an actor named Trevor Slattery who
was being paid by Aldrich Killian to
take credit for Killians plot to
experiment on extremis soldiers who kept
blowing up in at the time fans like us
were a bit disappointed because the
mandarins really a major player from the
comics and deserved a lot more than like
a silly twist up in in the Marvel
one-shot all hail the king slider he
gets interviewed and Seagate prison by
documentarian named Jackson Norris who
turns out to actually be an agent of the
real ten rings
he starts lecturing Slattery about stria
from Andrew himself he was a warrior
King inspired generations of Monza's
Middle Ages perhaps even further back in
time when Slattery tries to deny the
existence of the ten rings says it was
just a narrative he played Norris
threatens and for that sin you will soon
suffer horribly with a hole in your body
for every ring of our faith
Norris then kills all the guards he
reveals 810 rings tattoo on his wrist
and says there's somebody who wants to
meet you
Danah him no you took his name and now
he wants it back that was the last we
saw the tin rings in the MCU until a
deleted scene an ant-man one of the arms
dealers hoping to buy the yellow jacket
and Pym technology is seen in deleted
footage to have a ten rings tattoo on
his neck and now years later the ten
rings will finally resurrect in
shang-chi and The Legend of the ten
rings with the true Mandarin now in the
comics the Mandarin ventured into the
valley of the spirits of Chinese fables
and he discovered a crashed alien ship
containing
the ten rings of power which were alien
mcluhan technology Mandarin found them
as cylinders that he turned into rings
that he would wear on his ten fingers
each ring contains the soul of a
long-dead legendary cosmic warrior
trapped in a phantasmal state there's
the matter rearranger the impact beam
the vortex beam the disintegration beam
the black light which creates darkness
also a purple glow in your highschool
bedroom that you thought would look cool
but actually exposes all the gross stuff
you've been doing on your computer desk
also the white light the flame blasts
the electro blast them into intense fire
and ice blast and yeah we're talking
stuff that's pretty similar practically
speaking into the Infinity stones like
such a god mode cosmic jewelry but it's
different it's it's a it's different
when the Mandarin wore all ten rings
together the spirits controlled his mind
in order to try to resurrect these
spirits leading them to kidnap Tony
Stark and tried to force him to build
tight a no mechs as vessels but his
hidden work and then sometime later the
rings were made sentient and they took
on new names with new vessels and they
were hunted down by Malekith before
stark managed to contain them now
actually this comic run features stark
secret brother Arno stark whose
existence
I've speculated could have been hinted
at and that Howard Stark seen in
Avengers in game so perhaps this
shang-chi in the legend of the ten rings
film will feature a similar plot with
the Mandarin and the ten rings in which
this ancient terrorist network who at
every turn has been plotting to get
their hands on super-powered tech from
Tony Stark and Hank Pym was secretly
trying to find technological vessels for
these cosmic rings and which technology
have we seen recently capable of
containing that kind of power
what about Starks custom Infinity
Gauntlet from Avengers in game
think about it would turn those stones
back in time that gauntlet was still
laying around somewhere probably a
little crispy might still be working and
in the background of that scene a
mysterious helicopter can be seen air
lifting a crate away maybe that's the
ten rings stealin stark Scotland pretty
Guses in which case it would be on the
young shang-chi to uncover this plot
reach out to the other Avengers and stop
the Mandarin in the ten rings this
movie's director actually hinted that he
might want to include his longtime
collaborator brie Larson in the story
and as shang-chi Captain Marvel team-up
could be a perfect way to introduce his
character to the MCU family so what do
you think the Mandarin in the ten rings
plot will be in xiangjian The Legend of
ten rings comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at a boss and subscribe to new
rock stars or breakdowns and theories
about everything marvel thank you for
joining me and seriously never buy a
black light it's really just a trick by
Spencer's gifts to shame you in front of
your friends with too much information
about
[Music]